[Music]
we should all nice and light in talks we
still have room for more lightning talks
so if you're interested please email me
with all caps in the title we've got
some really cool ones lined up but we
have room for more
so I strongly encourage everybody to
who's not speaking in the main program
to please send me an email and sign up
for a talk it'll be fun
those are gonna be on Thursday afternoon
ok so just like just like Professor
Madhuri from MIT I decided to scrap
everything I said I was going to talk
about which is fine I think that's this
how this goes
come on Oh clicky thing works ok there
we go that's the same thing all right
good
now the animations are really ready to
go so we were supposed to give a survey
I started writing the survey and I got
bored this is the same thing that
happened to I mean I guess this is just
what happens so instead what I want to
talk about is actually a bit more
personal story than a kind of broad
survey because I think those are easier
to motivate so I'm gonna call this my
god Don Quixote tilting it well windows
talk and I know that everything in
iterative algorithms in every kind of
workshop I've gone to for the past
decade has all been about sub linear
algorithms but what I want to ask in
this talk is have we maybe missed the
vote a little bit and forgot about super
linear algorithms and maybe these are
actually possible even in our big data
world maybe and maybe we're actually
already running super linear algorithms
just don't realize it and so we should
be focusing on other things in this
space so this talk was assembled by
torturing some graduate students and
postdocs to get some content and that as
usual had nothing to do with the actual
what I'm gonna say has nothing to do
with what they intended me to say so
we'll see they'll be a different
divergence and all mistakes are mine
right so what's the holy grail of
optimization what's the one problem we
all want to solve the end of the day
it's fine an X that's the ax equals B I
feel like we had this primitive
everything would be good right this is
this is kind of our universal primitive
reardon ya know why is that I mean it's
also like kind of like it is the
solution that solving this problem is
also solving the solution of probably
the simplest unconstrained optimization
problem the positive definite or the
sorry the strongly convex quadratic
program and you know obviously this is
you can you can use this primitive to do
linear regression and classification
even though people argue with me least
squares classification is a perfectly
fine thing to do
obviously to solve interior point
methods at large scale or at any scale
honnestly you have to be solving every
every iteration requires solving a
linear system obviously if we want to
use some squares we actually want to
operationalize this and make this real
we have to be able to solve interior
point methods so as a result sum of
squares also even though it's
polynomials as of reducing back to
linear equations and there's all sorts
of optimization problems where we
actually use quadratic programming as a
subroutine not just an interior point
methods but obviously sequential profit
quadratic programming and Newton's
method are two other examples so it's
kind of like this backbone thing it
enables all sorts of stuff and it's also
funny oddly enough right that this
problem ends up being like the hardest
optimization problem for iterative
methods which is weird so it's like we
know that this is actually a in some
sense if we can understand how to solve
this
well we can actually you know sometimes
hopefully even move to nonlinear
problems either through sequential prep
quadratic programming Newton's method or
other kind of analogies okay so
hopefully everybody's wouldn't agrees
with me here least squares it's the
thing to do and in particular where I
will talk today is something that we
always kind of punt on is the dense case
when a has is almost has all the I'm
just not gonna assume that there are any
non zeros an a there could be some but I
really want to talk about the case where
this is almost full and I guess the the
the reason for doing this is that if we
could solve the dense case well we could
solve even bigger sparse cases maybe
right
no is that fair that's just feels right
to me its deficit so we can leave in
stock yesterday right like there was a
reduction to I mean so you use graph
structure to reduce a problem that's a
very sparse into a smaller dense problem
right so there's this kind of limitation
into a bunch of smaller dense programs
but underneath all of that you still
have dense programs that you have to
solve and you can make those larger it
even enables larger sparse solvers okay
so what I want to just talk about today
is solving ax equals B and trying to do
that as efficiently as possible so this
is a workshop on iterative solvers so we
start to look at it what you iterative
solvers do for least squares the
simplest iterative solver I know is the
steepest descent method but there
probably something even simpler steepest
descent just computes the residual and
moves opposite that residual right yes
right okay that steepest descent and so
what's the complexity well this is the
number of iterations times the flops per
iteration and the number of iterations
goes is like you know the lips just cut
you know the larger site actually I
guess it's positive definite now so it's
just the largest eigenvalue of a divided
by the smallest eigenvalue so it's the
condition number times log one of our
epsilon which is your desired precision
that's basically the number of
iterations you have to run and then per
iteration you have to do matrix vector
multiplies and then some accumulation so
it's about oh of n squares right so
overall this is an algorithm that takes
all of em squared time times some kind
of iteration based on how accurate you
want to get okay so first thing know is
it it is once we go to the dense case
not a sub linear algorithm because we
always hide in our Big O notation the
number of non-zeros in a so if this were
to scale somehow linearly if the number
of non-zeros was linear we'd have
sub linear algorithm but assume you have
any reasonable amount of density this is
a steepest descent it's not a sub linear
algorithm yeah no yes expect your
products with it with a and not the
Hessian right what you're saying so if I
have a fast multiply for a right
basically the amount of time it takes to
do the fast multiplies what you're
saying Mike right sure so if I have a
fast multiply for a this could be faster
but assuming no extra structure the
amount of time it's going to take is N
squared right that's a fair point
okay so what about other iterative
solvers and I actually I was gonna do
some casts of grading to set but I just
did I just did a coordinate descent
which actually in this case has a very
it has a different name right coordinate
just has a different aim it's called
Gauss Seidel and it's kind of want
something that we would learn in linear
algebra class but they're the exact same
algorithm and in this case what you do
is just one chord at a time which you
pick at every iteration usually a random
you pick a random coordinate and then
you just do this update which looks like
essentially one update of this what we
would do is cheapest ascent and it's
renormalized by the diagonal entry na
right this is the gauss seidel method
that people know so flops per iteration
here is less it's n cuz I look at one
column at a time but unfortunately
there's no free lunch here then the
actual scaling which I I think I got
this right Steve no sorry I still go
through C's paper I think I've got this
right the actual number of iterations
actually now increases so you actually
have to run linearly with them so at the
end of the day it's almost the same
running time as the steepest descent
method the main difference being of
course that there's a different constant
in the numerator there's something
called L max instead of capital L which
is actually related to the quadratic
cases just that's just the maximum
magnitude of the diagonal okay so this
is the maximum magnitude of the diagonal
as opposed to the maximum eigen value so
it couldn't be better but again it's
still N squared times some structural
constant and in some sense everything
you look at for this problem looks that
looks like something like N squared
times of structural constant about this
matrix some instance dependent constant
times log 1 over Epsilon now how long so
so it's not really something
dimension unless you have a fast
multiply for a meaning that either
either a is sparse or there's some kind
of mechanism to make multiply a quickly
and I think that the interesting part
here is that you know that to actually
just solve this system using I don't
know a to less key factorization let's
say takes about and it takes n cubed of
n cubed operations so we're kind of
we're playing with a little bit fire
here because this thing we better hope
is much less than n right better hope
that this number is much less than n yes
sir I don't know what sub linear means
Robbie actually I'm sorry I've been
attending conferences on sub linearity
for a lot of time I never know I think
self lidyr just be sub linear in
whatever number I care about so it's
like if it was n cubed and his less than
n cubed its sub linear and I don't
change is this definition from line to
line
that's what P order told me that stuff's
it's gonna go in like he told me sub
linear and whatever quantity you care
about so anyway for me usually stuff
linear me sub linear dimension though so
I think that's that's usually what I
have at least of the in my head as a sub
linear in n but um I I don't know okay
alright but the point is that N cubed
actually sounds really bad but when you
start comparing it to actually what
happens in these dense problems it's not
so bad and I mean I'm gonna make an
analogy that's not clear with least
squares but let's imagine we were doing
some kind of neural network training
we've gone to using stochastic gradient
descent on something that's very dense
and again like so we're it's feels
linear but since the size of the
networks scales with the number of data
points now we actually have there it's
also a quadratic time algorithm so
jumping from quadratic time to cubic
time is a factor of n it's not two
factors of n I think it's just in almost
all cases now trying to get to
algorithms that scales and cubed may be
reachable it's not as big a leaf as I
think we might have imagined everybody
seems skeptical so let me let me show
this to you let me show you through what
okay how about this one
and it's sixty thousand we did I had I
had advice all around this last night by
shells in the crowd today this is huh to
zeros
what
well you got square it ticket number
parameters that's big
what you up her app what do you want
what are you looking for the size of X
well the size of X right this it's six
it's sixty thousand by ten so you wanna
I'm going off by ten there that's fine
that's where we're trying to go mark
this is good
stay with me on this okay so sixty
thousand by ten here's the thing about
sixty thousand by ten is that we could
actually do this and on a server which I
will describe which server in a minute
that that by shell ran last night this
took 111 seconds to actually just solve
this directly with this site you know
whatever inside pi doing Linux off 111
seconds running block gauss-seidel we
ran it for three essentially three
passes over the matrix took 127 seconds
and if you actually compare the relative
error between what the direct salt gives
you which I'm going to X star and what
the editor salt gives you which I'm
calling X the relative error is point
five eight which is not great that's not
what I would call epsilon okay it's a
big big s lon usually F so has to be
less than half right
there's look at in the community are
anyway that's big
alright so it takes it takes he even
allowing these two things the same
amount of time you're actually not
getting a very accurate answer and the
question is are we are we selling
ourselves short with crummy iterative
methods because it does seem like the
that that for the same amount of time
budget wall clock which is what we care
about we can actually get a much higher
quality answer doing direct solve yes
Pablo absolutely right what is this K of
a yeah so here's one for the vault we
never know somebody has us it somebody
has us in matrix a I never know actually
what K of a is we prove theorems but
actually computing usually estimating K
of a is just as hard to solving the
problem
yeah sometimes we know sometimes we know
but but more often than not so for this
particular case anybody can probably
guess what I was doing here right anyway
for this particular case this was a
problem for machine learning there's one
data set machine learning that we use as
benchmarks way too much but anyway this
is actually the the condition number is
horrible it's a really terribly
condition problem yes yes so for the end
result that's another thing that
actually I don't want to spend too much
time on but this is actually a huge
mistake that the machine learning
community made I give this I talk about
this in other talks the fact that we
know that generalization error is going
to go as one over square root of n so
that means that we can optimize to 1
over square root of n first of all we
never optimize to 1 over square root of
n here right we didn't get that close
and second of all just because you have
a sum of two terms doesn't mean they
have to be equal like when you're
minimizing a sum of two terms you can
set one to zero and then the other one
might get smaller so anyway but that's
that's a lawyer digression which I can
tell you about but yes the
classification accuracy is much better
for this one so even even on this stupid
problem that shall remain nameless
that's right
dirty secret here ok so so why is it
faster though right because it's saying
it's still N squared versus n cube one
reason could be condition number which
Pablo is suggesting which is fine but
that's the condition number is really
just governing why this accuracy is so
slow why is it that three passes three
matrix multiplies essentially the same
same amount of flops as three matrix
multiplies matrix vector multiplies is
slower than doing a two Leske and I
think the one reason is that to get
maximum speed you have to randomize
these methods and randomization requires
data movement and data movement is slow
and it's something that we don't count
in our flop counts unless you're jim
demo and so maybe we should be more like
jim honestly counting communication and
counting movement is probably just as
important as counting flops and i think
that's part of one of the issues here
because if you start messing with moving
things back and forth in your memory you
start to actually lose time and the
second question this goes back to Mark's
point is that if I actually want to get
something bigger maybe I just need more
RAM right because so so how much RAM do
I need for 60,000 by 60,000 well okay
it's about 30 gigabytes to store that in
double precision and
solve is 111 and we did this on a
machine that has 64 cores and 2
terabytes of RAM so we have Headroom and
in fact like we could probably do 350 K
in 6 hours if we were so inclined all
right so that's that's bit that's
getting bigger that's getting bigger but
I think like you know there's another
number of a data set that will shall not
be named yeah ok ok so that's 12
terabytes that doesn't fit on this
machine and indeed it will probably with
this machine even if it did if I just
I'm just this extrapolation is just
assuming that we get perfect cubic
scaling so doing that extrapolation it
would take about 10 days which is a long
time so super linear scaling is the
worst so as I try to make these things
bigger it does seem like I will suffer
on the other hand the memory demand
growing quadratically what does that
mean so I think the biggest machines
that are easy to get that are not
ridiculously expensive have 4 terabytes
of RAM it's hard to get much beyond that
at this point although 4 terabytes is
still 4 times bigger than it was four
years ago so there seems memory does
seem to be still be growing even if
processors aren't getting faster and
cubic time scaling means we need a lot
of course right so we have we have
problem that we need a lot more memory
and we need a lot more cores but let's
let's say we had a machine that had
those we could probably solve this
problem if we can get access to you know
more compute right so the questions
where can I get access to more can this
computer right and I think also like
we're not even get access to this
computer and the answer and I've been
dragged kicking and screaming to this
regime because I'm not really fond of it
but the answer is always the cloud right
I mean that's that's the Berkeley
Berkeley has been big big on this and so
as the Bay Area and it's you know it's a
big big marketing thing and this is
magical place where you know there's
like all these machines and you could
have all of them and all of these
machines have a ton of RAM in them right
so get all of that RAM to and you know
the cloud even has like GPUs so if you
don't have a GPU in your house you can
get one on the cloud actually FPGA is
now which I still not figured out why
they're there
you know does anyone know what the use
cases from the FPGAs amazon has them
other than like I I think playing
arbitrage against the Amazon market but
why would you want it in the cloud okay
so Jelena is saying that like a lot of
times I mean well I know for FPGAs is
like if you if you do have some if you
don't want to make a chip but you want
something that's almost as good as
making your own chip you you program the
FPGA and you maybe put that on a robot
or you put that on a trading floor so
you can get some high frequency
arbitrage vanish so it turns out that
that actually is the only application
I've heard so far that I believe which
is what what examiner said I will
definitely repeat it as I say well a lot
of people are doing for circuit design
is using cloud FPGAs to try out so I can
just get hundreds of these things try
out a bunch of different designs and see
which one is best before I actually go
and print it so that's actually
something that we're folks in the aspire
lab here at Berkeley are definitely
doing and I think this is the common but
I don't know anyway they're there though
so if you guys have something you want
to do with FPGAs they're in the cloud
they're also like unicorns and their
rainbows and it's a magical place
oh right I mean there's a lot of
marketing that goes into the cloud but I
think having have expect a few years
with with with with everybody kind of
working on this stuff it's a little bit
it's a little bit daunting to get into
the cloud because you go and and you
start to look at like what was available
and it's just like a lot more than it's
a lot more than just like one random GPU
right and you have all these it's the
sipes
you have different providers that all
these different things and there's this
great website and I love this website
ec2 instances info and it lists all the
possible things you can get on the
particular region on AWS and yeah I
don't I don't know what you do it's like
going to the Whole Foods it's like you
just got all this great options and it's
kind of hard to figure out what's the
right thing for my problem so it rather
usually when you go and it used to be
you just go like you go to the Apple
store you just max all the buttons and
the massive computer you buy it right
but it's unfortunately not that clear in
the cloud that that's the right thing to
do so so this is that's
Eric Jonas quote someone's gonna put
that in there that's his hashtag please
attribute appropriately that the cloud
is too damn hard it is really hard it's
not as it's not as simple as just going
and like treating it I mean you you you
can just get single boxes like this two
terabyte machine that vice all got
yesterday and then treat it like a UNIX
box but even that interface is not as
standard as it should be and like I have
no idea what we're gonna actually what
what the right thing is to get and I
think the more important question is
these things cost money constantly right
they're not free they're not free so
it's very easy again named names here
very very easy to burn through all the
kind of Amazon grants that you get in a
weekend if you're not careful um and you
know so what do you do and again yeah I
don't know it's it's a bit it's a bit of
chaos so okay let me show you something
crazy yes if I didn't give you what you
paid for
[Laughter]
take type H top I guess is where you are
you it's a good thing why where did
these contracts come from how do we put
how do we trust how do you I don't even
know that they gave you the course on
the same machine you guys have an answer
it's actually an issue that the tendency
situation is sometimes complicated yeah
you're actually this hardware is being
multiplex to various hypervisors with
other providers so sometimes we actually
go through a benchmark you'll discover
that you know this Zeon machine have you
had it under your desk would give you
this performance I mean you run out at
AWS you only get this performance that's
right so the answer is you don't
necessarily so again that's another
that's a whole other issue of actually
what are you actually getting that's a
good question but uh for the for the
buck that two terabyte machine or
whatever terabyte virtual machine cost
two dollars an hour which is nice if you
just need to run like two or three mmm
dispense demos that's fine yeah for more
than that maybe you have to think a
little harder going back to the spectral
question if you have a densely picked
enormous size and has two distinct
eigenvalues yeah so in two iterations
sure the conjugate gradient do you have
that do you have that instance and
all the problems that I know including
your own networks and especially your
own networks have a lot of zero
eigenvalue so that so it's a
distribution of eigenvalues is not going
to come it you didn't believe my
experiment no I'm just I ran I ran a
random random kernel Ridge regression
problem I so sorry I respectfully
disagree I never have seen conjugate
gradient actually converge unless in
again we meet conjugate gradient to
convert into three iterations to be
competitive with directsoft5 to saying
we need to convert to three iterations
yeah and it does not but no problems
that I've ever captured have three
eigenvalues so it'll be fine but none of
the problems that I care about how three
eigenvalues so yes it's also with no
pre-conditioner yeah oh we've tried that
we talked
not exactly three zero eigenvalues but
small number of you know distribution
arriving bad versus a sharp drop and a
very different behavior than the
worst-case behavior of steepest descent
right stupidest and always has the worst
camp behavior right I'm sure so you're
giving us worst-case behavior of things
that's just the only thing I was going
to say yeah people do conjugate
gradients and I mean you guys could
route whatever you'd like
I'm just saying wouldn't it be nice if
you could just do a direct solve because
then you don't have to worry then I
don't have to worry about what the
eigenvalue structure is again it's just
n cubed there's no instance dependency
wouldn't that be nice yes okay so now
we're moving on that would be nice all
right so but again but then it's this is
dependent okay well how do you know I've
been get depends of being able to
actually get that gap small release
where's at least the briefing
can be such that you have a extremely
well can do some problem right yes but
again it depends on the instance no how
can it not because because the pre could
well sorry for for least squares yes
okay so so where you do a and
approximately QR decomposition and then
use that approximately QR decomposition
not sorry not for the general case of a
PSD sure but for least-squares sure
anyway I'm not this is fine we could I
mean you guys could use precondition or
suit again yes Robbie not being an
insider there are really all the
equation solvers already the cloud or
absolutely the promise there's like
again so like okay we have this tyranny
of choice we're the same thing in
optimization we have the exact same
thing in optimization there are a
thousand papers a day on some new little
tweak of coordinate descent or on a DMM
or on non-convex this and they propose
17 different things you could do more
preconditioners and there are lots of
things you can do there are lots of
things you could do
I see no papers telling me how to solve
these squares just exactly because maybe
that's a salt problem not that
interesting but I would like to be able
to do it it's a nice benchmark again
like I can get this I'm gonna go back
here I would like to be able actually
just compute this number sometimes and
so that needs this x squared X star
right so I actually think that there is
a difference there is a value and like
we can have like the tyranny of choice
does not end with just the cloud right
this is already a problem but I do think
that practitioners you guys what
algorithms you use
and the same thing the same thing goes
with neural nets what albums are use so
there are lots of tyranny of choice
let's prune ourselves today I'm gonna
just talk about one which is I would
like to be able to do directs off and
then we can that hopefully that I mean
that only that only fuss fixes one thing
which is the optimization problem I
still have to figure out how to actually
now do it which is another thing so let
me show you what that's also not easy
okay this is the here are we're just
going to look at a QR factorization an
exact you our factorization that we're
gonna do it by a tall skinny method okay
and what we have here is five different
configurations that all have the same
hourly cost and so this is that again
they're color bar this is the time and
seconds it takes for the exact same
hourly cost so we have five different
the same cost and we're getting a factor
of two difference in time and we also
get I mean it's actually kind of obvious
what's happening here memory bandwidth
is actually the important thing and so
there's a two ties to X performance
difference for the exact same price
which is which is a bit disturbing right
so how do you actually pick that right
so these choices actually really matter
um because that even though you have
like some ideal benchmark to get if you
pick something badly you can actually
have a fairly large gap in your accuracy
as well so I'm gonna just skip this
because it's gonna okay let me just say
see where we go here so one thing that
we're actually able to do I'm skipping
it cuz I'm almost out of time but I
wanted to get to something else is that
actually Chevron who is now at Microsoft
Research and will be at the University
of Wisconsin Washington sorry Steve
Brantford following Microsoft actually
has a really nice paper showing that you
can actually predict doing small
instances how the these things will work
on large instances and this is just
simple experiment design where you do
small instances and try to extrapolate
so by running essentially and let's see
if we can where's that bar that's pot by
running very small benchmarks you can
actually able to dramatically you can
actually pretty accurately predict how
big the how long the running time will
actually take on the big instances and
the training time for these
is very small so so there's a big gap
between actually she just runs small
little benchmarks that extrapolates out
to large things but again even here
right I think the point is is that
there's lots of choices and these
choices kind of matter and I would
prefer that they get hidden for me and
also I didn't tell us about RAM yet this
was just about bandwidth and and
configuration selection and we'd like to
actually skip all of that so for that I
want to talk about something that has
been we've been using in the group and
this is all Eric's fault so again the
remainder of the talk is all Eric's
fault there there's this funny thing
that Amazon has started supporting which
is called lambda alright which
apparently makes our lives easy that's
apparently that's what the infographic
tells me so what is lambda do just like
we think with lambda calculus it just
executes functions for us and it's
essentially these stateless server list
functions I tell Amazon execute this
function it executes it and puts the
result in this s3 bucket and what's s/3
s/3 is actually the part that I'm most
interested in and it's something called
the simple storage service and it's
essentially just infinite ram that they
charge you money to keep occupied so
well talk about the money there in a
second right but what's interesting it's
got to this to this weird blob storage
you have 600 megabytes per second per
machine which is the same speed as
serial ata it's a little bit slower than
a PCI bus but I get that per machine I
can get lots of machines ok and again
with the big thing that we were trying
to show in that previous plot was memory
bandwidth it's kind of the thing that
you want to maximize you will have lots
of cores with maximum memory bandwidth
so Erik over a weekend decided to build
something which was essentially just
instead of instead of executing one of
these guys would map we're just
basically over write Python map such
that would map to lots of lambda
instances and what does that do so this
is actually I think the part where it
starts to get a little weird and
interesting is that you could get if you
ask Amazon nicely 3000 10000 10000
simultaneous function executions on
10,000 different course right these
little tiny little flock of course and
their aggregate elephant teraflops at
about 3,000 workers is 45
teraflops which is like 10 GPUs that's
like 10 P 100's which is pretty cool
okay and you just and so and also the
aggregate bandwidth to the s3 is
approaching about 80 gigabytes per
second which is pretty nice so I was
kind of shocked by these numbers that's
pretty that's pretty nuts just doing
bunch of micro surfaces services you can
get some teraflops and so he built this
thing called pyrin because it was
supposed to be a flock of condors I
think is the idea if anybody remembers
Condor some people anyway if you don't
is fry for the best
but I just like to antagonize Marone but
he's not here anyway so but Pyrrha is
supposed to be kind of he's these little
guys they all flock out and they do
their jobs for you and it combines
Python I mean you just write native
Python and again you just he you
overwrite map so this just allows you to
kind of do simple map but it does simple
map it executes this thing in the cloud
and the way it works which is kind of
funny is you write some crap on your
laptop what it will serialize this and
puts it up in this this storage just
then you invoke lambda and then lambda
just does magic stuff where it pulls
this pulls this stuff runs the code you
ask for the result and eventually this
ends up in s3 and you get it back what's
funny is you just write crap on your
laptop and I never actually have to
worry about picking a server which is
actually now ship ROM can do all this
stuff behind the scenes and I have this
is this is now I feel like I'm
assistance person I have an abstraction
boundary yes everything behind the
scenes you never have to worry about and
the kinds of stuff that we can actually
do is just thinking about how do we
actually use map to try to do numerical
computation actually had a cloud here
anyway okay so now now this actually
atlas has asked some weird and crazy
things okay so remember all I wanted was
more RAM and the question is how
expensive is this blob storage s3 is
essentially infinite Ram it does I don't
know how much RAM is in s3 I'm just
gonna assume we haven't hit the limit
yet we haven't Olivia because the
problem is that they just start charging
you money but it's a little funny
the first 50 terabytes per month is
0.023 cents per what dollars point oh
two three dollars per
and if you have over five - it goes down
the more you store it so it's like this
is the beautiful part of infinity the
more you store the less they charge you
weight now exactly not exactly so here
let me ask you a question how much can I
get for a dollar another one of my
favorite slides that Eric has ever made
here there we go this is this is this
plot is blue my mind completely
simplified this is how much storage you
can get for a dollar so remember they're
charging you by the amount of time you
so for one minute I can get two
petabytes for a dollar that's a no
there's a problem who sees the problem
with this well I mean you still it still
takes a little while I mean less like
unless this is the three iterations of
conjugate gradient I'm gonna be in
trouble it's gonna take longer than this
and actually I can't write to it that
fast that was the other plot that we had
showed a few slides ago so it's kind of
superimposing our current lambda
capabilities on top of this so the
amount of time it takes to read and
write to this memory is too slow to
actually get a petabyte in and then to
delete it because again if you keep that
for two minutes that's two dollars and
eventually that starts to add up so so
what was so but there's this interesting
regime right here at the hundred
terabyte regime where we can actually
actively treat this as a hundred
terabytes of RAM that hopefully at the
end you remember to delete right okay
got some people here how to remember
delete because if you leave it for a day
we get in trouble anyway so so but this
is an interesting line so how do your
algorithm this is actually I think this
is like the open problem of this as your
algorithms change if you have infinite
memory but it comes out at limited rate
and I don't know the answer to that
could be iterative - let's not you know
your iterative algorithms change if I
have infinite memory but it comes at a
limited rate and it's kind of this that
so we had that in the previous slide
right this is the beyond pspace
what if that part doesn't matter and I
think we know that algorithms do change
if we don't if we don't have to consider
that kind of memory requirement so let
me close by trying to say how we do
linear algebra okay and we're calling
this numpy Ren which I don't like the
name but that's fine everybody missed
sorry I'm just announcing it it's too
long none prior in anyway so something
that's up that that's hopefully
everybody knows is that actually to do a
matrix multiply that looks like this
where I have long times tall is one of
these really trivial things to do in
MapReduce so this is kind of one of the
standard examples that people have in
MapReduce because what I do is I just
partition this guy into blocks and this
guy into blocks every worker gets those
and then it reduces the sum right so
that's kind of a steric thing to do in a
MapReduce framework but there's other
things that are actually a little bit
harder to do that are actually
primitives that we need to do at least
to do actual esky factorization which is
where i'm going to close is that you
actually kind of have to do like large
rank updates so yeah sorry low rank
updates where I have to actually form a
low rank matrix and add it to a big
matrix okay so this is this is really
hard to store in memory so it's hard to
do with single workers and eight
terabytes of memory even for a
traditional clusters a pain in the butt
even though we like the max single node
we can get is four terabytes and how
much of the four terabyte machines
something like 14 in 20 bucks that I
were here so two terabyte but this is
actually where this is interesting I
know that this week has been a lot of
memory remembrances of Michael Cohen but
the last conversation I had with Michael
was actually about this stuff and he was
asking where is it become nonlinear in
terms of memory and actually the
interesting question is that I mean as
everybody knows now Mike Michael was
interested in everything so when did
this become nonlinear in terms of memory
it's about at that four gigabyte regime
so to two terabytes terabytes thank you
so two terabyte machine I can get for $2
an hour four terabytes is costing maybe
$20 an hour so you're kind of pushing it
up there and it's also expensive if you
try it
any time I have to build a cluster it's
really annoying so what if I treat this
thing this kind of s3 thing as RAM and
what what would you do so what we can do
is use s3 to store the matrices and then
use the lambdas to kind of operate on
each of these blocks right and I'll put
everything in parallel using the shared
Ram disk and I think these are old
numbers but I sold actually gotten this
a little bit faster that's why Sean and
so for these kind of 1.2 million
dimensional problems mark was asking
about the you could actually do in less
than an hour you can actually do these
kind of take a little reg matrix do the
outer product stick in an s3 at fairly
fairly fast rates good so this gets to
the end how do we do Chi Leske everybody
remember how to do Chi Leske okay good
so so we want to have a factorization
that looks like this and I'm gonna do it
by blocks we're let's just say we're
gonna do a block cholesky I'll get I
want to actually make this factorization
so L 2 2 is much bigger than L 1 1 this
is a little tiny little block this is a
huge block so that's the partitioning so
how do you actually go about doing that
well the first thing you do is you take
that first block and then you take a
chill s key factorization of that that's
easy you can do that I mean that's that
you can do on your cell phone but we're
not I don't think there are cell phones
in the cloud maybe there are and then
the nice part is that this part is free
I get to zero that out so how do I do
the next updates well L that the this
first column is just simply I can just
broadcast the L 1 1 and multiply it by
the every guy so that actually looks
much like a Map Reduce thing but
trivial to also do it in this kind of
pyrin framework and then this thing is
the interesting case because that is
this low rank update so low rank update
is 82 - these l1 201 2 transpose blocks
ok so each of these guys get hit we can
do that one in parallel and that allows
us to actually do the two less key ok so
I'm gonna stop there and so Jorge and I
have time to fight I think that there's
something interesting here
whether or not actually it's director
iterative the fact that this that the
cloud actually opens up these potentials
of having very kind of unusual I mean
they're not unusual if you were doing
parallel computing in the 90 so I'll be
fair like having this two layer cache
but where the memory layer is infinite
is very interesting so I actually do
think there's interesting stuff that can
happen if we can actually implement and
make open source these kind of like
simple linear algebra tools that people
can use through Python for example we
can actually start to run big sums of
square programs which we're currently
we're currently memory limited by and
similarly like a lot of these kind of
interior point methods I think we can
start to prototype at a larger scale I
think there's interesting things that we
can even do in the sparse case which I
didn't discuss today because I was only
focusing on dense because a little bit
easier to think about but then we could
even do it a larger scale when we start
to move to to incorporate sparsity and I
think that there are fun and weird
algorithmic challenges in this kind of
not only non area methods but in this
funny model for infinite ram that i
would love to talk to you any of you
guys about at any time ok
yeah cats got no access what's really
what's very odd is that a lot of Map
Reduce was initially designed for things
that died we there's definitely
straggler effects and I guess
occasionally you will get processor
failures but with the nice thing about
lambdas is that because you're not
actually loading a server if it dies you
could just ask for it again there's
certain idempotency so if something if
something strapped and you get they've
built in straggler mitigation into into
the pyrin interface so but I think there
it's funny like MapReduce was built to
be very very fault tolerance probably to
a fault you know there's a there's
always hard to actually I don't know how
much fault tolerance you need
unfortunately it's hard to know how much
fault tolerance you need until you
really need it so this is all about how
conservative right yeah yeah yeah this
is how conservative you you need to be
no okay he's good Jorge's good yeah do
you have any examples where you have
like I say million by million matrix
that which is dense that is like coming
from South Africa yes that's a good
question so so cute one doesn't know
there's like I have very Li I have
numbers that were like machine learning
dog whistles in here so I don't know if
everyone so I think only maybe not
everybody gets those spelling me okay so
one machine learning dog whistle is that
60,000 that's the size the amnesty to
set this 1.2 million number is the size
of the image net data set which is kind
of this big one in computer vision this
is like the bit this is was the thing
that made deep learning a thing was that
data set and so you just want to say if
you actually want to use that that's
where I got that 1.2 million number
there are speech data sets that have you
know 20 million examples so most of the
things I have are coming from machine
learning but an easy way to generate
large distances for least squares is to
try to work your way up the list air
hierarchy so I mean very nice structures
which and also forming the matrix is
actually the most important most come
consuming part it's not actually solving
a linear systems but that should be in
our advantage here yes because what are
you limited by that's great actually I
think that's great so what are you limit
about your limb by Ram that's one thing
and then you're limited by forming a
which can be done in parallel sometimes
right and so those so if I don't if I
can do a sparse solver at the end that's
great
why were you will looking at that so I
burnt you looking at that kerosene da
normal which is kind of sure I should
have written accuracy in the a norm that
would been fun it would not have been
better but I could I should have written
it that way I didn't we just did no no I
I just mostly actually the thing I
really care about which is stupid
because I do too much machine learning
is out of sample prediction on the test
set right that's the only thing you
really care about you never care about a
norm accuracy sorry again that's a
terrible joke I'm just saying it cuz I
have to friends from Google here in the
front rail so we don't see it's not
significantly better if you look in the
a norm again it's just really to get I
think to get to the kind of precision
that you want which is even ten the
minus three in the a norm requires tens
of passes with the kind of matrices
we've been looking at I agree with Jorge
there are instances which actually will
be solved faster by doing you know
coordinate sorry that conjugate gradient
will solve more quickly than this but
again like if I've got a lot of myself
20 conjugate gradient iterations as my
upper bound that's what the direct saw
becomes competitive do you need more
than twenty passes through the data they
take your optimal of of southfork
complexity on amnesty yes do you need
more than ten passes probably not but I
haven't got a that's at a sixty thousand
minutes pass was an N squared operation
yeah no because it's assuming that that
complexity term is assuming that could
the condition number is a constant so
asymptotically it's true just like let's
let's say we do get in passes
yeah that I think your gain is actually
coming from building the matrix in
parallel one no it was just in the saw
it wasn't the it's that that we require
less data movement because even to do
the n passes while conjugate gradient
doesn't require this but conjugate
gradient to converge requires I mean you
know it's always less than n but
sometimes it requires hundreds of matrix
vector multiplies for the randomized
methods it requires a data permutation
and that's always what people do in
practices they just do two permutations
and all that's right that's right that's
right that's right but then you have to
analyze that one actually so one thing I
didn't mention and I guess that we
should take a break salt take this and
last question one thing I didn't mention
is actually even two permutations is
significantly slower than just doing
pure with replacement sampling for
coordinate descent you a block
coordinate descent you really want to be
able to every time take a fresh sample
we have we have a there's a nice paper
we were surprised by this but breaking
locality actually gives you a
significant win in both standard gauss
seidel and accelerated gauss seidel
so your motivation for doing this bin is
to do exactly the exact Newton methods
even just these squares classification
and yeah actually I'm interested in to
your methods
or let's say Ben
[Applause]
[Music]